hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to today's video today's
Thursday uh September 29th 2022 and your
Market had a big down day you know we're
down about two and a half percent
and you know that that's uh following up
yesterday where you know we basically
had a nice rally you know Tuesday we
sold off
and then Wednesday we rallied back up
and now Thursday it's almost like the uh
you know the mirror image the opposite
of what happened on
the day before so
some interesting things in the order
flow I want to talk about and you know
I'll get to these imbalances a little
bit later but um you know one of the
things I want to talk about is
you know someone signed that you know a
market is is starting to Trend right in
order flow there's many different facets
if you will of order flow that can help
a Trader determine you know are we going
to be reversing or you know is there
momentum in the market you know for this
trend to continue and
you know it's where it gets interesting
is because you know there's so many
different little nuances in the order
flow that
you know Traders sometimes forget that
they have to differentiate it from it
because you know when people trade using
you know indicators or
things like that you know all they know
is oh there's a signal I gotta take it
or not basically you know is it red
light or green light but with the order
flow there's all these little nuances
and for me you know determining whether
there's momentum in a market is by
watching the volume
and the easiest way to do it is point of
control point of control is the price
level in the bar with the most volume
and if a market is moving obviously you
want to see points of control right the
price level where the most volume is
transacting you know over bars move
lower and lower
another way to check is also is the
volume in a bar migrating lower within
that bar as well
okay because you know most of us are
familiar with
the volume profile right I mean we've
all seen it on a chart you know the
daily profile you got your D shapes your
P shapes your lowercase b shapes
Etc and you could even do that on a bar
by bar basis and you know when the point
of control right because you have point
of control in a in a profile as well is
in the middle of the bar you know that's
your normal place that you don't expect
it to be you know sort of in the center
you know your normal distribution day
right your D shape where the most volume
is you know sort of concentrated towards
the middle it's when
on a bar by bar basis you start seeing
each point of control subsequently go
down right if your Market is trending
down but then within each bar where it's
appearing is the point of control
appearing near the top it's appearing in
the middle or is it appearing towards
the bottom in the middle is where you
know you would normally expect it in a
normal Market condition if it's
appearing somewhere near the top
I'd be looking at where are we trading
relative to
um you know where that point of control
is you know if we're at like a high of
the day or swing high and I see points
of control coming up near the top of the
bars then that's sort of telling me
their supply in the market however when
a market is moving it's going down
I'll be looking for point of controls to
be coming in you know towards the bottom
of the bars because what's that is
telling me is that
Traders
are accepting lower and lower prices
okay and
as opposed to you know rejecting them so
if we're accepting lower and lower
prices
then chances are we're still going to go
lower okay so you know today was was a
great example of that right we had a
nice sell-off you know cash opened up
and you know it was interesting is
because it doesn't really happen very
often as you know when cash opened up
the cumulative Delta for the day which
is obviously the the Delta for the whole
session up to the cash open is right
around unchanged it was mine it was plus
187 then Cash open went minus 700 okay
so it's like basically starting at zero
which I said oftentimes you come into
the morning and you know cumulative
Delta is
negative 5000 or positive five thousand
you know it's very rare that it's like
that
sorry about that phone was ringing and
um you know so humans have Delta was
sort of negative so it's kind of neutral
even though you know at this point you
know we were you know it was a little
bit lower right 8 30 this morning you
know 8 30 where are we here uh
this is like around 8 30 right here okay
because we closed yesterday you know we
closed much higher 37.32 overnight we
had that nice sell-off during the early
morning of Europe
but you know we're coming in here at 8
30 in the morning and we're trading
about 30 points lower okay
and cumulative Delta was right around
basically flat okay so yeah that's one
thing to keep an eye on you know which
way is the market going to go so
obviously negative Delta negative Delta
first couple minutes you know we're next
thing would notice we were down about
two thousand you know 1200 in the Delta
but cumulative Delta's at minus 2200.
okay so obviously that's a bearish sign
now point of controls right they're
appearing sort of in the middle right
you got the first bar that opened up
it's a little on the lower end okay
but then the second bar you know kind of
in the middle the third bar it's coming
up near the top okay so again like I
said when I see
point of controls coming in near the
high of the bar it's telling me that
there's probably some Supply in this
market right people were you know
because again when we're putting this
point of control at 92 and a quarter you
know we're still sort of going sideways
at this point you know trading 92 and a
half all the way up to you know 93 and
three quarters so it's still within the
range you know sort of this opening
range but now we're starting to break
out of the opening range
and we start coming in lower right we
got that nice stack selling and balance
and what do we got first bars point of
controls here but then the second bar
it's at 95 and a quarter next bar 92 and
a quarter
the next bar after that 86 and a half
and it pairs it up right you got two at
the same level okay not a good sign put
a control
next one at 84 and three quarters so
lower lower lower lower
but they're all sort of you know in the
middle except for this one it's a little
on the high end I know that
um you know we're still on negative
Delta and then but I know the low is
coming up close right we're coming in
hot to the low lows here at three and a
half and as we start getting near the
low again you know we're sort of Point
control is sort of in the middle then I
get this bar Point control right near
the bottom okay and again this is just
right off the lower three and a half
this is so this is about four points
away
then we get this big bar down point of
control near the bottom two stacks
selling imbalances so again looking at
two bars with pointed controls near the
lows there
okay then a third bar again point of
controls migrating down everyone is
lower lower another one right near the
low so I got three when it controls
right near the lows okay and so that's
telling me that price is going lower
obviously I mean these are red candles I
mean it doesn't take a a
rocket scientists and say oh price is
going lower but more importantly
volume and as a result value is also
going lower now what a lot of people
haven't really been talking about this
week I don't know maybe I missed it is
you know vix is in the 30s again you
know all week we've been in the 30s back
in August we're trading 19. I don't want
to say the teens because I think we're
just around 19 and in the 20s
but you know it's gained a lot in terms
of uh volatility so I know that I'm sort
of expecting
wide-ranging candles this is an e-mini
one minute chart you know like this bar
here is 78 and three quarters
down to 71 and a quarter so you know
that's a seven point bar you know that's
about on par with you know a vix at
these levels
so I got one two three point controls
near the bottoms of the bars
another one here
okay we're obviously going lower volume
is going lower
and that's the important thing to to
sort of keep in mind is you know the
heavy volume is going lower look at the
uh
cumulative Delta obviously negative
obviously it's growing because you can
get some big bars here minus a thousand
Delta then sort of you know Point
control in the middle okay put a control
in the middle I'm going to control
you know on the lower end but really all
you got to do you know that you're ready
printing Point control is lower just
look for that break down here to New
lows coming in you know around 71 70 and
a half
you just drop a stop in there
okay now here you got a couple selling
imbalances to hide behind so you got you
know one aggressive push another
aggressive push although this aggressive
push looks just like a stop that got
triggered
Market came back up Trader where traded
right up to this point of control now on
a trending market watch your point of
controls because those are often the
levels where the market will retrace
back to and here you go okay look at
this so Cash open right over here lower
lower lower you got these two pointed
controls this bar we opened up at 86
rallied right back up to 86 and three
quarters where that previous point of
controls were
okay then we go down
um you know here we opened up above
start trading lower so we got this
two-pointed controls obviously you got
that one in the middle it's a little bit
higher but this one and this one are are
the same price look at this bar we
opened up at 79 and a half we traded
back up to where 80. so we come back to
this these two pointed controls we came
back to these two pointed controls
this one opened right on the point of
control here
and immediately went down so you know
that's another thing that you could look
for on a trending Market are these point
of controls holding you know because
they are going to become irresistance
right now if the market was rallying I'd
be looking at the point of controls to
be support I'd be looking for opponent
controls to be up near the highs
but um yeah I mean so I want to get back
to you know that's how you can use point
of controls to help determine you know
are we trending or not
um you know sort of going back to the 7
30 time I mean there was that big size
in here at 36.90 okay you can see what
traded in the footprint uh 1496
you know earlier came down there we
tested at 36.90 bounced up you know the
numbers came out and then it hit there
once 210 rallied back up
and then the third time it came in here
right 36.90 broke right through it right
and
when it broke through it it did it
pretty quick now you know when there's
big size you know sort of this resting
liquidity in the market you know people
that trade on a dome they're sort of
trained to see the big size and jump in
front of it okay there's 1500 on the bid
here fine I'll buy 90 and a quarters
right and then there's going to place a
stop right below it
but once this breaks
now it can break pretty quick and hard
so you know and the thing is you know
for big Traders you know if well I know
when I was working at JP Morgan and you
know I had some
um selling to do and be like yeah you
know I say oh there's a strong bid there
at 90. okay so you know I'll just be
sounded here at 91. you'll scale some
stuff in here but as this bid starts
trading out you know this 1500 Lots
if I see it you know getting down to
you know a thousand okay the 900 500
once you get below like about 300 it can
trade just like that someone can just
come in and whack it and not only that
there might be some stops here you know
these guys are trading on a dome getting
long in here at 90 and a quarter 90 and
a half or bounce back up like happened
here
but once that breaks you know they got
their stops in there you're going to get
that effect like this where just no
counter trade zeros here so obviously
there's not like two-way auction just
the one-way
um runaway train going on right here
sorry about that I don't know why
everyone decides to call me right now
but um once that volume breaks it's very
quick and
when you got big volume like that it
breaks very fast a lot of times you
don't necessarily retrace back up to it
anytime soon you know in this case we
never got back up there for a while
until just before cash opened I mean
this was at 7 34 it wasn't until like
here eight
so about a half hour
um before we came back up there it's not
like we're going to break and then just
sort of rotate around come back up when
you have that big support in the market
and you break through that
it could be a while before we come back
up and what was interesting obviously
you got that big stack styling balance
up here you got a bunch of stacks
selling and balances you know this Bar's
got two obviously but that's at 7 30
when the number comes out here you got
one
here you got one here you got two right
you got mostly stack selling imbalances
and again in my opinion it's it's these
are due to the volatility around the
number
but you know we met once we broke that
from 90 we trade all the way down to 73
and a half so almost you know there's
almost 20 points
no yeah 20 I can't think right now but
yeah from 90 all the way down to 73 and
a half we did bounce back up
again we came back up to where that's
why you know I like having these zones
drawn out because I know that okay I got
a stacked selling a balance here from
earlier this is going to be a potential
resistance here you see we came right
back up to that area traded two
contracts into it at 86 and a half and
came back down to you know in I don't
say 80 but you know 80 and a quarter
here but you know 81 82
all right then I know I got this other
level coming in here the low is uh 88
and three quarters okay we got within a
couple of ticks here we got as high as
87 and three quarters So within a point
and then we reach it here finally this
is 757. we trade a couple contracts in a
couple ticks into it here 87 and a half
89 that's right 87 three quarters 89.
and you drop right back down to 85 right
in the next bar
I didn't even go down lower and down
into the again not 81. I need to get 81
but you know 82
but really you know this is these are
these easy trades right when you're
looking at these stacks on abouts just
like you got stack buying a balance you
got aggressive buyers coming in here
okay
is it worth a shot if this one holds
right if we trade back into it and it
holds where we're gonna go we're going
to go back up either to this level or
this level
okay now I'm getting not all the times
they work so nicely like this but you
know that that's something you gotta you
should look at in in your trading you
know we all love to have sort of levels
to trade around but when you're trading
you know with order flow the order flow
is giving you levels is telling you
where there's aggressive buyers are
active
and again you know I also like to use
point of controls as support or
resistance areas
right because you know that's the price
level on a bar where the volume is
transacting at right so that's important
to know you know sometimes the way I
like to describe it to people is is
almost like
You Know Jack and the Beanstalk right
it's like you know when someone were to
come up to you and say hey you know what
I can show you something that
you know where the market can turn
basically
you know on your chart we're just using
information from what's actually trading
you know would you be interested in that
yeah you know you should be if you're
just looking at at a normal bar chart
like this now this is a five minute
chart people are going to say well yeah
you know I see people draw out zones you
know almost indiscriminately and say
okay well yeah I got this Wick up here
so that's my
um resistance zone right so what they'll
do is they'll do something like this
okay yeah I got this resistance Zone
okay well you had one here that failed
right I mean you can draw zones out
indiscriminately you know here here you
know it's a support Zone here right you
can see these two candles
it's nice double bottom here and they'll
say yeah you know see it went up but
they won't show you the part that where
it just dropped like this right then
here right a big wick down here yeah
that's that's your support Zone and it
just ate right through it very fast
right just with with nothing to stop it
whereas if you're looking at the order
flow you can say yeah you know what I
have a level here because earlier there
was aggressive selling
earlier there was aggressive buying
all right so you know I started out this
video talking about point of controls
and I moved to imbalances so you know
there's just so much information that
the order flow gives you so I'll add it
there if you like this video be sure to
uh you know hit like be sure to
subscribe if you haven't subscribed
already so thanks everyone bye bye